That leads me into my next question. How
do you know that Islam is inherently
violent? So if if you're going just by
scripture, isn't that true for
Christians as well, the Bible like come
with a sword, etc.
>> Right. Right. Okay. So the difference is
this. You have the scriptures, but it's
not just the scriptures. So you have the
calls to violence in the Quran. Then you
have what's the hadith, the teachings of
Muhammad. Okay. And Muhammad's
considered the perfect example. Every
Muslim supposed to follow him. Okay. in
the hadith you know or the sunnah which
is the example of the prophet as derived
from the hadith is essentially with the
Quran the twin pillars of Islamic
epistemology if you will and that is
full of violence and intolerance okay so
both the Quran and the hadith more so
the Islamic jurists who are looked upon
the as they're called have distilled
Islamic law based on these two texts and
they conclude that things like jihad is
absolutely obligatory which is I have to
go fight and conquer and spread Islam
and subject ate the infidel etc etc that
I have to place the dimi or you know
secondass status okay the whole nine
yards okay so that's Islam so it's in
the text it's in their law okay and you
know look around Muslim countries I see
it's still happening so there's a reason
that when you look at the 50 worst
nations where Christians are being
persecuted 37 are Muslim okay so we got
that now Christianity okay so the old
testament certainly is full of violence
the new testament you're right I myself
am an advocate I I wrote a book called
the two swords of Christ where I
reference Jesus in Luke where he tells
his disciples, "Whoever doesn't have a
sword, go sell your garment and buy a
sword." And they say, "Look Lord, here
are two swords and here that's enough."
Now to modern day Christians, of course,
they allegorize this into
meaninglessness. It means nothing. Okay?
To preodern, especially medieval
Christians, it meant that two swords you
one is a spiritual sword against
spiritual enemies, which modern day
Christians, I think, still acknowledge.
But the second sword is a secular sword
against material enemies. Okay? And
that's what they don't acknowledge.
Okay? So I I myself do believe that the
New Testament certainly makes room for
just war. Now the pivotal difference is
this. So I mentioned the texts and then
I mentioned the actual teachings and
codification. I don't know of any
Christian theologian who says we have to
do holy war until the world is converted
to Christianity. Okay? Because the texts
don't support that. They do support
self-defense defending the innocent, the
widow, the orphan and etc. Okay? But
they don't and there's one more other
aspect to this which actually the Old
Testament. If you look at the Old
Testament, the violence that God,
Jehovah, Yahweh calls on the Hebrews to
engage in, it's always directed against
finite temporal people who have a name
and an identity.
>> They fight the Jeb, kill the Jebusites
and the Hebrewites and etc., etc.
>> Interesting. Yeah.
>> Those people no longer exist. So even if
I'm reading that, these are not even
real people. It's localized to a finite
group and time. The Quran doesn't do
that. It's a very open-ended language.
It says in the present, fight the
non-Muslim. Even though at the time the
non-Muslim could have been a Persians or
Astrian, a Byzantine. So it's taken on a
transcendent eternal logic. It's not
just, you know, okay, yeah, the Hebrews
were fighting the people in that region
and you know that's the end of it. So I
think that's a big difference in my
opinion.
>> Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.